season one of loki was a mind-bending
trip
to the outer reaches of the mcu as
always
marvel packed in plenty of easter eggs
from obscure 90s product placement to a
ton
of fun references to marvel comics and
other movies
here are some small details you may have
missed
while the marvel studios animated logo
rolls at the beginning of episode 6 you
hear steve rogers and peggy carter's
song
it's been a long long time play as the
tune begins
several famous lines uttered throughout
the mcu can be heard
it's a mixed bag of more than a dozen
catchphrases punchlines and tender
moments
we hear steve rogers talking to himself
in endgame which is fitting for a loki
episode
i can do this all day yeah i know most
of the lines we hear
are from major mcu characters like the
hulk addressing loki after he tosses him
around like a ragdoll
puny god but we also hear everyone's
favorite kiwi accented rock monster
korg hey man we're about to jump on that
ginormous spaceship
you want to come and we get one line
from a disney plus mcu tv show
and of course it's the one the internet
just couldn't get enough of
but what is grief if not
love persevering
there's some indistinct overlapping
chatter at the end of this opening sound
collage but a few other familiar voices
can be heard throughout the introduction
as well
as we view the timeline's physical
expression voiceovers can be heard from
several real-life heroes the first comes
from neil armstrong saying
one small step for man followed by
climate activist greta thunberg
shouting how dare they activist malala
yousafzai can be heard saying my dream
followed by nelson mandela saying we
have fought for the right to experience
peace these real world quotes are
wrapped up with the poet maya angelou
saying i will rise
in addition to serving as a sweet look
back at the mcu's past
this introduction also offers a nod to
the franchise's rapidly approaching
multiverse
after all as the mcu begins to embrace
the concept of countless realities
who's to say we aren't part of the whole
phenomenon slipping a meta brain bender
into the opening credits
that's so low-key there's a lot to
unpack in the first two minutes of
episode six
after it's been a long long time fades
out tchaikovsky's main score from swan
lake fades in
the famous ballet centers around odette
and odile
two versions of the same character
odette is a cursed queen who is forced
to live her life as a swan during the
day and a human at night
odile is the opposite in all respects a
bewitching presence who disguises
herself as odette in order to trick
prince
siegfried into falling for her in the
ballet the two parts are often played by
the same dancer
loki and sylvie's story is much like
that of swan lake as it's essentially
two versions of the same character
battling one another while the ballet
ends on a rather happy note with odette
and prince siegfried coming together and
living happily ever after
we don't go into episode 6 expecting
happy endings for loki or sylvie any
time soon
in episode five all signs seem to be
pointing to the impending appearance of
kang the conqueror and the finale
episode six confirms those suspicions as
kang appears in the flesh in the citadel
at the end of time
jonathan magers was confirmed to play
kang in the upcoming ant-man and the
wasp quantum mania in 2020
so while his name is never uttered in
loki episode 6
hardcore mcu fans knew who he was as
soon as he appeared on screen
miss minutes meanwhile introduces him as
he who remains the tva string puller our
heroes have been questing for
and a familiar name in the comics king's
history in the comics is long and rather
confusing
creating countless possibilities for the
mcu first appearing in 1964 1964's the
avengers number eight
king is born nathaniel richards and
lived on earth
6311 an alternate version of the main
marvel comics reality earth 616.
after discovering time travel he
journeys to ancient egypt and becomes
pharaoh rama tut but is met with
resistance by a time traveling fantastic
four
setting up a long and incredibly
convoluted chain of events that seen him
battle and ally with numerous marvel
characters
during the ensuing decades kang also has
significant
ties to ravana in the comics and with
her on the loose as the loki finale
closes it's hard not to assume she'll
meet up with one of the many versions of
kang who seem
likely to appear as the mcu's phase 4
moves forward
the penultimate episode of loki on
disney plus was a
wild variant-filled ride that set up
what is sure to be a mind-blowing finale
it was also jam-packed with fun easter
eggs for fans to find
here are a few you may have missed in
episode 5 journey into mystery
at the beginning of episode 5 we travel
through a destroyed cityscape
full of decrepit buildings most of these
structures
seem like filler to emphasize the
destruction but there's one significant
easter egg hidden within the rubble
that's worth noting
toward the end of the camera pan a
building on the right reads kang
q-e-n-g at the top of it marvel comics
fans should know this famous name as
it's related to a major villain who's
set to appear in the mcu
this tower represents kang enterprises
and if you thought it looked like the
avengers tower you weren't wrong
in the comics it's revealed that stark
industries sold the building to the
company and avengers vol
6 number zero from 2015. the ceo of kang
industries is mr griffin aka nathaniel
richards who exists on earth
6311 an alternate version of earth 616
the reality where all the main marvel
stuff goes down
nathaniel richards is also known as kang
the conqueror as the latter was split
into two different versions of himself
due to a time stream error it's a
complicated story from 2015's all-new
all different avengers number one but
this nod decang
a major villain we know will appear in
ant-man and the wasp quantomania
is something that we can't ignore during
episode 5 one of the first things we see
in the void is a menacing purple black
cloud with a monstrous face within it
this is the void that's goliath
and where his lunch come on known as a
transtemporal entity eliath doesn't
exist in any reality but instead what
the comics describe
as temporal limbo the being is the
biggest enemy of kang the conqueror and
its empire is bigger than his foes
eliath first appeared in 1993's avengers
the terminatrix objective number one
and is known for its absorption powers
which we saw play a huge role in episode
5. eliath is drawn to living beings more
than
anything and has the power to
disintegrate them as soon as it
encompasses them
in the mcu it appears as if eliatha
lives within the void at the end of time
unlike its location in the comics it's
also being used to protect the person or
entity behind the timekeepers who many
now suspect to be kang
if this is the case in the mcu the two
would be on the same side
a massive shift from their comic book
origins
in a move we never thought would happen
the thanos copter became canon in the
marvel cinematic universe
thanks to loki episode 5. when the mad
titan finally perished in avengers end
game
it looked like we might never see the
famous aircraft but now we
know why we never did the thanos copter
first appeared in 1979's spidey super
stories number 39
and was a helicopter the villain used
one time to attack hellcat
a popular marvel hero who fought the
titan as he tried to obtain the cosmic
cube
thanos also picked up deadpool in the
helicopter in deadpool vol
5 number 45 when the latter was hired to
help the mad titan steal the cube
it's such a shame we never got to see
that scene play out on the big screen
fortunately loki episode 5 paid homage
to a great and frequently mocked comic
book moment
the thanos copter matched its comic book
appearance exactly with its bright
yellow paint and the titan's name
written across it in large bold letters
we knew we'd be getting a version of the
trickster god from the classic vote loki
comic after he appeared in several
trailers for the series
and he finally arrived in episode 5 but
only for a brief scene where a scuffle
breaks out between a gaggle of loki's
as for the variant's origin story the
four-part comic series debuted in june
2016 and was a satire on the united
states presidential election of the same
year
in the fourth and final issue loki
concedes the race
in the comics loki's campaign is based
on his honesty about how he's going to
lie to the american public
the citizens eat it up except for a
reporter from the daily bugle who's
trying her best to take him down
it's definitely one of the weirdest loki
stories of all time
complete with political action cults
sacrificing goats
and we're incredibly glad this dapper
and politically ambitious loki got to
show up on the screen even if it was
only for a few minutes
just before the loki group makes their
way down to their secret hideout we see
different layers of rubble
above their little base and buried in
all this debris
we get a glimpse of mjolnir and a small
glass jar with t365 written on it
trapped inside this jar is a tiny
version of thor
and one who's a bit more amphibious than
we're used to seeing the god of thunder
known as throgg this powerful frog
version of thor first appeared in thor
number 363 although number 365 is more
significant for the character because
it's where he lifted mjolnir and became
the thunder frog officially this
coincides with mjolnir being just
out of throgg's reach in the episode as
he's trapped in the glass jar
thor number 365 also heavily features
loki who suspects something is afoot
with his brother
it's a hilarious storyline which
includes thor helping an
army of frogs battle an army of rats
just as with db cooper in episode 1
episode 5 of loki further explained some
great american mysteries
the first to appear in journey into
mystery was polybius an arcade game long
considered an urban legend
the legend of polybius suggests this
fictitious 80s game was real
and run by the government as a
psychological experiment
it was supposedly created to test mind
control on users
but the arcade game was never found it
looks like it was swooped up by the tva
and sent to the place where urban
legends go to die in the middle of
episode 5 we also see the uss
eldridge fall out of the sky and into
the void unlike polybius the famous
naval ship was an
actual thing in 1943 it was alleged that
the ship was made invisible
as part of the famous philadelphia
experiment
as some claim it was also apparently
teleported from philadelphia to virginia
and back again
crew members who were on board
reportedly went insane
and the story was so bizarre it was
adapted into a time travel movie the
philadelphia experiment in 1984.
since episode 5 mostly took place in the
void set designers had a major
opportunity to include an incredible
amount of easter eggs from the mcu's
past
some of these include ant-man villain
yellowjackets helmet in the first act
which we saw as we panned over the
landscape and ronan's dark ouster
spaceship also makes a brief appearance
we also get a brief look at a demolished
telecarrier sitting in the wasteland
also in the vast devastation across loki
episode 5 is what appears to be a stone
face of the living tribunal
which we know isn't an mcu relic yet
one of the most important entities in
marvel comics is the character who first
appeared in strange tales number 157
from 1967.
the living tribunal basically oversees
everything ever in every reality
serving as somewhat of a judge of the
entire cosmic universe and all of its
realities the tribunal is more powerful
than
all of the infinity stones combined
episode 4 of loki was the most revealing
and game-changing installment yet
the episode also had some treats in
store for marvel comics fans and
mcu diehards here are a few easter eggs
you may have missed in loki episode 4.
one of the biggest surprises to come in
episode 4 is the return of jamie
alexander as lady siff
we haven't seen the character in the mcu
since 2013's
thor the dark world and while we
suspected the missing hero might be
returning her appearance was still
shocking nonetheless siff's cameo was
brief and those unfamiliar with norse
mythology might have missed a famous
story hiding in plain sight
when she first encounters loki siff is
holding a lock of her dark hair
she charges at loki beyond aggravated
that he cut off her tresses
and calls him pathetic and conniving in
addition to other
unpleasant words she aggressively knees
and punches him
and loki has to relive the event over
and over as he's stuck
in a time loop while it might seem like
a storyline the loki writers conjured up
they actually pulled it directly from
the two characters mythologies
in the norse myths unlike the mcu siff
is known for her long golden hair
in the myths loki cuts off siff's hair
which puts thor
her husband in a fit of rage after his
brother charges him with replacing her
hair
loki travels to nedevelir where
stormbreaker was forged in infinity war
so the dwarves can create
new hair for sif out of gold which would
grow once placed on her head
we finally get a look at the time
keepers in episode 4 after their
appearances were teased with tva
sculptures throughout earlier episodes
of the series
when loki and sylvie are brought before
them to be pruned
the time keepers give them a chance to
speak we don't get much out of these
mysterious beings although their disdain
for the loki variants is obvious
with the help of hunter b15 who's had
her memories of her pre-tva life
restored by sylvie
the loki's are able to battle and defeat
their captors
and sylvie severs the head of a
timekeeper only to discover that they're
just
androids beyond disappointed loki and
sylvia are left wondering who created
the tva
marvel comics might have some answers
the time keepers first appeared in
1979's thor number 282
and were created by he who remains
someone unmentioned during episode 4.
also known as him who remains or more
simply
him this mystery being was the last
director of the tva who put the
timekeepers in place to oversee the
organization
originally him created the time twisters
in 1976's thorn number 243
another trio of beings who strayed from
their directive and began destroying
earth every three thousand years
in loki the time-looping devices used by
the tva are known as
time twisters in an apparent nod to
these characters
sorry the time twister just loops you
not the furniture
while we don't know who specifically
created the tva in the world of loki
he who remains or the time twisters
might have some insight
different versions of loki are teased in
episode 2 during a briefing mobius gives
to a group of minutemen and other tva
workers before they take off to oshkosh
wisconsin
these variants are displayed on a
hologram which depicts five different
versions of the character
none of these guys however match the
four new loki's we meet in the episode 4
mid
credit scene thanks to the credits we
know these variants
are boastful loki classic loki and kid
loki oh yeah there is also a crocodile
loki
classic loki sports the traditional garb
the character war when he first appeared
in 1962's journey into mystery number
85.
kid loki has a much shorter history in
the comics first appearing in 2010's
thor
number 617 this incarnation came about
after the original loki died but he was
reborn as a child who eventually joins
the young avengers
the backgrounds on our other two
variants are vague
but boastful loki's possession of a
hammer could be a nod to 2020's thorn
number four
in this comic thor's brother is able to
lift mjolnir while on yottenheim
loki was also able to lift mjolnir
during marvel's axis event when his
moral alignment was reversed which made
him the god of
heroism comic precedents aside boastful
loki's appearance at least hints at some
sort of confirmation that a loki variant
is worthy
as far as the crocodile goes there seems
to be no history of this character in
the comics
we've seen a frog version of thor before
aka throgged the frog of thunder in
2009's lockjaw and the pet avengers
number one
and loki turns thor into a frog in thor
number 363.
so hey why not a crocodile loki
after loki gets pruned he winds up in
new york city where he meets his new
variant buddies
most of the focus in the scene is on the
new loki's and while your eyes are drawn
to a crocodile wearing gold horns
there's something major you might have
missed in the background avengers tower
previously known as stark tower is
looming
in the distance absolutely destroyed
we've seen the building take a beating
before but nothing like this
the new loki's appear to be hiding out
in another apocalyptic event
although this time it seems to have
already happened as opposed to previous
episodes when the events were imminent
avengers tower is decimated in this
timeline with its top floor balconies
obliterated as it rests on a tilt
it looks like the barn door protocol
wasn't installed on this former
superhero hangout
like it was for avengers hq in end game
marvel studios loki has introduced a
whole new variant on everyone's favorite
god of mischief
with the mysterious sylvie running
around the timeline with loki in tow
the mcu is getting weirder than it's
ever been before
here are the easter eggs you missed in
loki episode 3.
much of loki episode 3 is spent on
lamentis 1
a rocky purple skied moon facing
imminent destruction
the episode is even named after lamentis
which has briefly appeared in marvel
comics
debuting in 2007's annihilation conquest
prologue number one
it lies on the outskirts of cree space
that appearance is basically just
dimension which means that for all
intents and purposes lumentus1 is
basically a blank slate for the marvel
cinematic universe a perfect spot for
loki to continue delving into its
narrative mysteries in other words
loki and sylvia arrive on lament one
after escaping from ravana and her
minutemen following a skirmish
outside the elevator doors leading to
the timekeepers they land on the moon in
2077
12 hours before it's set to collide with
its planet an
inconvenient apocalypse for them to hide
in but with their temped low on juice
this odd couple of loki's is forced to
make the best of a bad situation
not the only tech savvy loki don't ever
call me that
texavi no a loki after sylvie and loki
sneak on board the shuttle ferrying
ticket holders off lamentus 1
they have time to start getting to know
one another so naturally talk turns to
their love lives
sylvie remains as cagey as ever but
tells loki she's managed to keep a
long-distance relationship going with a
postman as she runs from one apocalypse
to another
managed to maintain quite a serious
long-distance relationship with a
post-man
whilst running across time from one
apocalypse to another at first
this sounds like a joke as if she could
maintain any kind of relationship given
her current life path
but as it turns out there's more than
one postman of note in marvel comics
that fans may know about
first appearing in 2002's morlox number
one
postman aka david is a mutant who lost
control of his powers and
accidentally wiped his wife's mind he
seeks refuge with the morlocks based in
chicago and eventually becomes their
leader postman ends up losing his mutant
abilities thanks to the scarlet witch
whose no more mutants decree in 2005's
house of m
number seven wipes the mutant gene from
the vast majority of its carriers
of course sylvie and postman don't
appear to have a clear connection in the
comics so we'd say put a pin
in this one it's not necessarily a hint
that the postman character is coming
but across the movies and tv shows of
phase 4 the mcu
is clearly setting up something and
it'll be hard to know what were real
hints and what were just coincidences
until the series lays all its cards on
the table multiverse
mutants who knows another famous postman
is willie lumpkin the
friendly mailman most known for his
appearances in the fantastic four comic
books
and also for dating mae parker and the
amazing spider-man
so who knows maybe sylvie had a thing
for him there may look like there's a
bit of an age gap but these are loki's
we're talking
about looks can be deceiving or maybe
sylvie really is just pining for a hunky
delivery man she's never been able to
settle down with
it wouldn't be the first time in
asgardian super being has fallen for a
regular joe
or jane we are treated to some fun
callbacks to earlier mcu chapters in
loki and episode 3 is no exception
once loki and sylvie work their way onto
the lamentis shuttle they sit and
converse in one of its upper scale
lounges as they talk loki helps himself
to two glasses of champagne
and sylvie ends up falling asleep when
she wakes her new travel companion has
treated himself to more beverages
and he's putting on a show for the other
travelers in the lounge
after singing and giving cheers to
sylvie loki smashes a martini glass and
yells
loyal mcu fans will notice this nod to
the first thor film
the line and gesture are uttered by thor
when he visits a diner with his new
earth pals jane foster
eric selvig and darcy lewis it's drink i
like it
i know it's great right
the line is one of the most quoted from
the original thor movie which feels
so long ago at this point all of these
characters have been through so much at
this point
it's nice that the mcu can still slow
down and show that it remembers where it
came from
disney's loki is off to a fantastic
start with the first two episodes
positively packed with fun details and
homages for marvel
comics fans to find here are some easter
eggs in episode 2
you may have missed at the beginning of
episode 2
several minute men traveled to oshkosh
wisconsin in 1985.
they arrive at a renaissance fair where
they believe the loki variant is hiding
out
at first it might appear like oshkosh is
a totally random place for the writers
and producers of loki to select for a
scene like this
but there's actually a sweet story
behind it mark greenwald was a prolific
marvel comics writer editor penceler
and celebrated marvel continuity expert
which is why the appearance of the comic
book version of mobius is based on
grunewald
and why owen wilson gets to sport a
mustache in the show
mobius appearance isn't the only homage
loki pays to the late comic book legend
as it turns out he was also born in
oshkosh wisconsin
according to his new york times obituary
grunwald died at age 43 following a
heart attack in 1996.
there are hundreds of floors that make
up the tva which is full of winding
hallways and curvy architectural designs
loki and mobius take several elevator
rides throughout the first few episodes
traveling to all different kinds of tva
departments in episode 2
they land on level 372 where mobius
instructs loki to read through all of
the variants paperwork
to see if he can come up with any
theories or suggestions why 372
the time variance authority made its
first appearance in thor volume 1
issue number 372. the use of 372 as one
of the floor numbers in loki is a nice
nod to the organization's origins and
suggests
viewers should probably take a second
look at all numbers that pop
up in the series loki can only access
his own file at the tva
so we get to witness loki read about the
events of ragnarok which he hasn't lived
through
at this point in time while he's looking
through the documents we
see some new tidbits of information
about the event that we witnessed in
thor ragnarok
the paperwork shows that there were 9719
casualties in what's described as a
class
7 apocalypse mobius confirms that
ragnarok wiped
out most of asgard's people and we know
from avengers end game that the
survivors are currently living on earth
in new asgard a more lighthearted easter
egg hidden in the ragnarok paperwork is
the mention of the revengers
the makeshift superhero group is
assembled by thor and includes valkyrie
the hulk and
loki the foursome bond together to
escape zakar and
are instrumental in the takedown of
hella thor jokes about their group name
in the film but the group helped save
hundreds of asgardians from death
justifying their mention on the document
in episode 2
loki mobius and a team of minutemen
travel to alabama in 2050.
they are there to sniff out the missing
variant who loki suspects is hiding in
apocalyptic
events the group arrives in a rock's
cart parking lot and the store name
is too reminiscent of a famous marvel
comics corporation to be ignored
the roxon corporation which has gone by
many names
is an oil conglomerate that was first
mentioned in 1974's captain america
number 180.
clearly this is the same company now
roxcart has worked with both shield and
hydra but their alliance will always lie
with whoever can fill their pockets the
most
blinded by dollar signs roxcart deals in
heavily illicit activities
sometimes with the universe's biggest
villains in thor number six volume four
roxcart worked closely with malekith to
receive exclusive rights to mine any
other planets he overtook
in the mcu the corporation was mentioned
by the mandarin in iron man 3.
thomas here is an accountant for the
roxon
oil corporation and the brand has been
featured in other marvel live-action tv
projects including agents of shield
there's been a long-standing rumor that
lady loki would make an appearance in
loki so when a female antagonist popped
up toward the end of episode 2
a casual fan and rumor follower might
just assume that we've got ourselves a
lady loki
well not so fast my friend in the
english credits at the end of the
episode actress sophia di martino
is listed as playing the variant however
if you look at the spanish credits elisa
bouter is credited as playing
sylvie that name might ring a bell to
longtime marvel fans it seems like this
variant is
actually enchantress a character who
first battled thor back in 1964 in
journey into mystery issue 103.
enchantress's real name is indeed sylvie
now we've seen the mcu get cute before
with cameos and such
looking at you one division so we can't
guarantee you that this is enchantress
lady loki still might pop up eventually
in the series or this is another of
those
silly mcu twists enchantress is the new
lady loki
after the variant sets off multiple
reset charges at roxcard in 2050
the sacred timeline is thrust into chaos
as judge renslayer watches the
pandemonium in her office
her computer screen displays several
locations that appear to be affected by
all of the meddling
while some of these locations we've seen
on more than one occasion in the mcu
like asgard and vormir the others we
only visited once
hala is the kree home planet and the one
that carol danvers trained on for many
years and it appeared in captain marvel
xandar made its appearance in guardians
of the galaxy but we know the planet was
decimated by thanos just before the
events of avengers infinity war
in thor ragnarok we visited the trash
planet of sicar which the grandmaster
oversees
while titan is the home planet of thanos
that saw an epic battle between the
villain and part of the avengers in
infinity war ego is of course the living
planet and the setting for about half
of guardians of the galaxy vol 2.
loki is the third marvel series to land
on disney plus
and the premiere is just as strange if
not more than the frequently
mind-bending wand division
and like wandavision there are some fun
easter eggs tucked away for marvel fans
to find
when episode 1 of loki kicks off a brief
recap of the events leading up to the
series plays out
after loki is captured at the finale of
the avengers we see him escorted by the
superhero team to the bottom floor of
avengers tower
as we saw in avengers end game a
disgruntled hulk
causes a future tony stark to drop a
briefcase containing the tesseract which
then bounces in front of loki's feet
the trickster grabs the cube and
vanishes disrupting the entire time
heist
we find out that this portal's other end
was in the gopi desert in mongolia where
loki drops out of the sky
his head sticks out of the sand as he
lays on his back the desert's landscape
partly covering his green and gold garb
while it's a brief moment in the
episode's intro it's also a major
callback to the mcu property that
started it all
iron man when tony escapes from his
captors in that film he flies off into
the sky but he comes crashing down into
the desert sand after his home-brewed
suit
malfunctions breaking apart into
hundreds of pieces
and leaving him dazed on the ground the
shot with loki is a nice nod to the
first iron man
and a pleasant parallel that depicts the
aftermath of two men who have just
escaped capture
after loki is captured by the tva he's
taken to their headquarters he signs
some paperwork
walks through a temporal aura detector
and then takes a number as he waits to
see a judge for his crimes against the
timeline
while waiting he's treated to an
educational video produced by the tva to
explain to variants why they've been
captured
hosted by tva mascot miss minutes the
video goes into detail about the
creation of the tba and how the
timekeepers monitor the time stream
miss minutes then explains that when
variants veer off their predetermined
course
stepping off your path created a nexus
event
which left unchecked could branch off
into madness
lead into another multiversal war
this isn't the first time we've heard
the word nexus in the marvel cinematic
universe
and the last time wasn't long before
loki one of the six one division
commercials
seen during the series show within a
show is an advertisement for nexus
antidepressants
nexus because the world doesn't revolve
around you
or does it nexus will be a significant
word and concept moving forward in the
mcu as evidenced by the title of the dr
strange sequel dr strange and the
multiverse of madness which is being
written by loki head writer michael
waldron
in one division the nexus drug was being
advertised as a medicine for wanda
maximoff's grief and anger and also a
reference to her role as a nexus being
loki is poised to further explore what
the term means in the mcu
when loki is apprehended in the gobi
desert several tva officers arrive
through a portal to capture him
while it's not specifically stated who
they are or what their title is
these guards seem to be a nod to marvel
comics minutemen based on their purpose
and uniforms
first appearing in fantastic four number
352
the minutemen are charged with policing
the time stream as these tva guards
serve the same sort of purpose their
appearance is a nice easter egg
in the marvel comics the minutemen are
actually robots not human beings as they
appear to be in loki
however it should be noted that at the
beginning of episode 1 a tva worker
asks loki to clarify that he is not a
fully robotic being
do a lot of people not know if they're
robots it's probably nothing more than a
throwaway gag but marvel is nothing if
not tricky
who knows the guards or minutemen could
actually be artificial
sure owen wilson's agent mobius is a bit
of a time cop but that's not why he's
sporting that mustache
in the comics agent mobius's look was
based on the late mark grunwald a
prolific marvel comics writer and
editor known for being marvel's resident
continuity expert until his untimely
death at age 43 from a heart attack
so it makes sense that the live-action
mobius would keep the stash from the
comics and bring this sweet homage to a
marvel legend into the
mcu check out one of our newest videos
right here plus even more looper videos
about loki are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you